*Laughter*
Crowd: OOH!
That's rough.
None of these things are exactly like a skateboard.
Who's this guy?
Brett is from Georgia
He was out here in the early days
He played the Battlefield soldier in The Glitch
Brett was in Footlose, and how he's back in L.A.
I needed some help producing this video
And I said c'mon! Let's do it.
So it's really good to see him. I haven't seen him in years.
We're gonna go kill some dank wasps!
The backyard is infested
With creepy crawlies!
There is only one, reasonable thing you do
Blast them with Raid!
I kill the wasps. Kill the wasps. I kill the wasps...
We are going to find the nests of the wasps
They will be terminated
Without any public trial.
It's gonna be great, they're gonna die.
And then we'll never have to deal with wasps again!
*Laughs*
I'm racist against wasps.
Kill them!
I got em'!
They're drowning in the shit!
Drowning!
There's one back there!
Cmike: Woah, woah!
Derek: Cmike where's the other one?
Sam: So I just had the most eventful Big Bear Market run in my life.
So I go there, and I'm gonna snag like you know, Coke Zeros and Sabritones which are my favorites.
But, that's not all I got on my trip.
First off, I noticed that had like new jet lighters on display and stuff
The guy said something in Spanish, and then the guy was like, lifted under and puts a pipe down
And I'm like, "That's a fucking crack pipe."
*laughs*
And the guys is all like tatted up and super skinny and shit.
And I was like, "Oooh, so that's crazy."
So I come back and I'm walking down the street
This freaking like, Land Cruiser goes *fast car noise* past me and I'm like, "Who's driving 50?"
Suddenly, another Honda goes *fast car noise* past me and I'm like, "What the fuck is going-?!"
And like they almost collide at the end of the street, and like I'm sitting there going, "What the heck?!"
The Landcruiser backs up and the other guy parks, blocks him in
Opens his door and freakin' takes out this huge knife
And I'm like, "OOOH!"
And they guy walks up to the guy and just goes *doosh!*
And slices his tire
Gets in his car and goes off, freakin' reverses out of there 50 mph
The other guys is like *confused noise* and like, starts driving after him
And the car is going *tss tss tss tss tss*
And goes flat in front of the VSauce office
And I'm sitting there going like, "Dude what's going on today man?"
*Everyone starts laughing*
Jake: Hey just another day, man!
Sam: Just another day.
So that's a little shocking, man.
So Hunter Street , back to its roots, man!
Back to its roots, you think it's getting gentrified; all the hipsters moving in, no dude.
It's crack pipe alley still.
Street fights, knife fights, *sighs* all the good stuff.
Wren: Oh hey what's up?
Guess what's in the corridor store?
Fresh in stock, go check it out!
Derek: *High pitched squeal*
Cmikes, where's the other one?
Cmike: One right there!
By the flowers!
Derek: I can't kill the flowers!
Cmike: He's by the yellow thing, by the yellow one!
Derek: Oh there he is.
You bastard!
It's not dead yet!
I would attack the walls...
*High Pitched scream*
*More screams*
Cmike: There it is.
Kill the wasps. I kill the wasps. I kill the wasps...
Derek: It was a disaster for the wasps I'm telling ya.
End of the story end of the line is: you just don't mess with the best, ya know?
Human beings
We are the best, we are the keepers of nature.
We dominate all, so...
I had to show them who's boss
Another day in the life of a Corridor employee.
What else can I say?